we know we did raise the retirement age
and raise the social security tags back
in nineteen eighty-two it's the
Greenspan Commission I because we knew
that you know the baby boomers had all
been born by that and we knew was coming
and most estimates suggest that what we
did back then is if not quite enough
almost enough social security on some
estimates actually is solvent for the
indefinite future on there the more
cautious estimates it might possibly
face a financial shortfall beginning
sometime the 2040s G on the list of
problems we have that's way down you
know it's it's always interesting to
have people who say oh don't worry about
the budget deficit now don't worry about
how we're going to pay for the Iraq war
but worry a lot about what might happen
to the Social Security system in 2043
boy you know that not not not at this
point I think the best thing to do as
those securities say of the various
parts of the federal government that's
one of the parts that's invest in the
best financial shape